Oh who's no Queen and I'm not bad at not
just snowman I'm I'm the carrot and this
is sibling rivalry stop the winter
please
don't you see I can't
let's go bring back summer
I'm not leaving without you Elsa only
Princess Anna can warm the heart of The
Snow Queen in frozen Disney's latest
animated Princess Belle I'm just gonna
call my kisses genre now it really is
the little princess edition on the
princess genre if we're gonna do fur
this is a to Yahoo princess nice one
becomes a queen which is pretty friggin
rare but we'll get to that
okay so we have this movie here at
Disney's latest princess genre animated
film and just been getting critical
praise like man a lot of people are
saying like you know this is as good as
Beauty and the bees everyone is really
glorifying it yeah they're kind of right
I'm gonna go that but it's good
I'm really torn because I'm like it's
good at the same time I'm like my
comments and executing the beasts I'm
like it's good I don't know what like
let me say this the first two thirds of
this movie I think are just again it
makes me feel like I'm watching pure
Disney again you know the songs the
animation everything the last third is
where I get into it's good and that's
probably the issue I'm having cuz it was
rock solid and then it just goes good so
the last thing I remember is it's good
yeah so so we'll get a little bit to
another spoiler corner um but pretty
much the the set up is you have these uh
uh you have this one princesses do
little girls who has this power can
freeze things I mean it is the Snow
Queen
um I don't think there's a sister in
there but I could be wrong okay but let
me just say straight up that Hollywood
you really need a new credit
Loosli baby yeah dad dad dad
like loosely based on the heads
Christian Andersen story so just ignore
that part of it
so so you got um uh II got Elsa and Anna
and their princess is one was born
disability can just free thing touch of
something freezes can dry anything the
ice seriously injures her sister when
she's younger and everyone's afraid
because there's this huge prejudice and
people's can think she's a monster so
they tried to make it so they take use
of these magic trolls that they erased
the sisters memory of
and just the acknowledgement that she
has this power at all but because of
that that to keep him really secluded
and really far away because then there
is a really dark open
yeah well MMB first twenty minutes of
this film I'm like I just kept my easy
little Disney logo flash yeah dark
things happen yeah of course you have
the parents died and I think you're all
but dizzy Sweden is graves I was like
when you wish upon this time well that's
McDonald's look this isn't good does
like okay yeah dude yeah so so so you
got that going on so years passed by
Elsa is of age she's gonna be the queen
she she's appointed Queen is afraid
because she is not in control for powers
and that she's finally outed and things
get out control everyone saying she's
this horrible creature its she's pretty
it's pretty much x-men you know in
Disneyworld uh so uh she decides to run
off in toto its x-men at Epcot Norway
this is what it it's uh so you got her
running off into the mountains builds
her own castle and everything is in
permanent winter so her sister has to go
to snap her out of it along the way she
comes across colorful characters
possibly the love of her life and all
sorts of high jinks ensue
um yeah like it the first thing I
thought of people might saw the trailer
first thing I thought is this is tangled
in Christmastime and it's not which I'm
really happy it does sort of have its
own thing going on despite the fact they
look tangle ish um you know it does sort
of look like Rapunzel in different wigs
oh yeah i I'm wondering if we're going
back to that back when that horrible CGI
Final Fantasy movie came out they were
talking about this concept of one
character model and treating her as if
she was a star so they would just change
the aesthetics like different wings and
Disney just perfect it it cuz yeah I'm
thinking the same thing I'm like oh so
it's the same girl model from tangled
yeah although my visit she does make a
big game of freckles and different hair
got it did you catch the Cameo and they
were pie
yeah swagger um but uh is so many good
things to talk about this one I think
well when I did this nice ember I was
talking about princess in the frog I was
talking about tangle and I said
somewhere between these two movies if
you could mesh them there's like this
really brilliant anime film trying to
get out and it seems like this is it
because then a miracle yeah and what I
really like about is that they take
Disney is very much it's gotten really
ridiculed for being misogynistic and the
fairy tales are real life and see you
later so to be honest why don't they
tried this time no no they really it's
slowly but surely they've been trying to
make these changes but they have a real
difficult task because Disney really
sells in the princess line is like huge
it's baby steps it's like we've got the
next baby step it's like this one but I
think this was still a really good kind
of baby step I think because you have to
make these steps you have to do this
while still making it while still
pleasing the general sort of Disney
Princess loving audience and still
having it be entertaining while still
having good morals and by God did they
balance it well in this especially with
this idea you get later we're on the act
of like true love is going to save the
day again
Disney cliche but how it's done is so
much better than how they're leading you
to think it's going to be done and it's
just such a good strong moment and on
top of that you have sisters in this
which you rarely see you got like you
said you have two princesses watching if
we didn't win y'all won yeah one yawns
we is acquittee and it's not a good
Queen a princess who becomes a queen not
to say man they just mean is not a
villain I mean I'm not the villain yeah
they make that very clear that you know
it's very much wicked
i source it it's like Disney's version
wicked write down the fact that India
Menzel was doing the singing voice
otherwise yeah it really is wicked s
yeah and it's like obvious but having
just seen wicked I'm just like yeah so I
get here but it's still effective um and
the songs in this are really catchy and
really good segues can be a little
better but that's an epic um my only
we nitpick and this may be on me is I am
NOT in the this new Disney mode of we're
gonna do post Sondheim style Broadway
with like modern instrumentation and a
real like wicked like it's a lot of it
sounds like wicked and when you see a
fairy tale sort of setting and it's
Disney you have certain expectations and
you expect like the Beauty and the Beast
sound the you know Tim Rice sort of you
know and I I'm not saying it's a bad
thing
I'm just not used to it yeah when you
know what to get that sort of really
modern Broadway sound out of this movie
I'm like whoa am I in the same film now
I'll tell you why I didn't mind the
songs I didn't like the segues because
I'll tell my wife on the way there and
she was like well how do you say way
into a song and I said when she there's
a scene where uh
the Snow Queen she's she's climbing this
mountain and he hear a piano and I said
when did you hear a piano in any of the
score in this it that's where it gets
really distracting there's only two that
disconnect between the songs and the
musical score yes I mean they grow
elsewhere that it's a deer house of
songs which is fine but yeah there is no
good way the segue into it and like I
was kind of really mesmerized by the
number of songs early on yeah and they
didn't a lot I kind of thought this will
like I seriously was like a third of the
way into this and thought is this gonna
be straight a musical is this gonna be
like 20 songs with very little dialogue
and the whole thing and they fade out a
little bit near the end no I figured out
a lot like somewhere after the halfway
point it really became about the action
and then there was more dialogue and I
kind of wish they had struck a balance
of like I used to do more later but no I
again it's I was impressed with the
songs actually even the ones I thought
were gonna be filling the troll ones
kind of filler but even though ones I
thought were yeah because I was gonna
song yeah babies and boys songs were
good they still you find out later
although they do serve a purpose uh and
that's kind of anti Randy Newman yeah
like everything
7-up one or two songs in like yeah I get
it a couple of the Toy Story songs are
really cool and and I like them but a
lot of the song Randy Newman songs like
those Pixar films is like okay somebody
wanted an Academy Award nomination I get
it it took a while but you know so
here's your song and this one it really
they all felt good III think you said it
felt like a musical and didn't feel like
okay we gotta hit our five we got Lion
King it we got a Beauty and the Beast
day or whatever cuz even during that
whole Renaissance thing that is what
they're doing here's your five songs
maybe you want to come back but here's
your five songs and and we're good I
honestly I did say it felt like wicked
I'm like okay yeah songs are driving
this story until a certain point where
yeah they kind of just oh like maybe
they didn't have faith maybe they
thought kids were gonna flee if there
were too many songs but you know this is
almost like Nightmare Before Christmas
yeah and it's hell they do but yeah it's
just a sheer number of songs until it
kind of slides a day that's actually
great example how the segue songs in
very well night before Christmas I think
it very well and of course the guy did
the score also did the song yeah so it's
all interconnected yeah so but were you
ready to hate that snowman I was ready I
was I had my wee horn in my drink ready
to just chuck it at the screen and I
there were so many moments where I came
close and he actually said something
legitimately funny and I'm like oh oh
you and like this character could have
been so easy to turn to the most of it
and we really thought I was gonna be
your most obnoxious thing but you dodged
a bullet listening you dodged a bullet
hey oh did you dodge it it's I'm
listening I'm waiting for the voice to
go annoying but what they do which is
really clever is in this performer uh he
had the voice go quiet which is really
smart cuz you're not seeing it coming
and it's it's er this new kind of comedy
that's catching on they think especially
kids they'll say it's like instead of
going really well like uh crazy ass I
think it's really quiet and it's hipster
cafe yeah I kind of do like
we're gonna be really subtle and sort of
oh that's what you like all of his best
lines were delivered with a whisper yeah
so it's they just got away with it but
I'm glad because I didn't want to put up
with annoying character and he was funny
so it's close like I it was finally near
it was the last ten minutes of the film
I think we're fine I was like no you
need to mount now I'm really done
just go away but the fact that it took
me that long to get to that point
whereas like I hate this guy now we'll
play Disney well played so uh yeah so
for me we'll talk about um sort of the
third act when we get into spoiler
corner because he really got talking
about it uh I yeah but I think to try to
sell this phone cuz it is it is good I
don't think it's beauty quite beating
the Beast good but I will say this the
best thing I can say about it is I hate
saying this with Disney's back
yeah it really like it really is like oh
so this is like the sort of film that
you know you would wait for as a kid
like cuz you used to be that that whole
slew from Little Mermaid through I don't
say but maybe Hunchback mmm
you know and you know it's like AHA's
was the first yeah you know what I mean
Hunchback was pretty strong but yeah
there's a time where as like as a kid
you would just you would wait for a
Disney film like ooh ooh ooh and then
you know you grow up and that's part of
it but even that as an adult you know
you you want a Disney movie where he's
like no I want to see a really good
animated a big epic enjoyable good songs
good characters and all the care that's
we're gonna bring up yeah what a great
cast care wonderful cast I they were all
really likable and they were very unique
and I again you don't see it was until I
saw it that I really you don't really
see sisters in many young dynamic was
really fascinating because that opening
was so cruel yes I like stories about
siblings appreciate abject rule T in
children's films like
I really do and and it's well set up and
yeah I'm trying what it visually looks
wonderful
I okay I will talk about this visually
the the backdrops the layout great
layout artist by the way that Doug
Walker guy yeah I know my Walker was in
a - yeah I'm glad we found work even
into CG cuz we've been animators
apparently for like only way - like we
already notice that yeah we first know
Zoomer maybe yeah but Allen's where we
noticed it when we saw land back when we
saw John Walker than we saw Rob Walker
we just want you're like 10 12 yeah we
saw like a Doug Walker - Rob Walker and
the credits and we laughed and it's
still funny cuz they're still working we
made the transition to CGI to us so yeah
there's a Doug Walker - Rob Walker but
yeah the layout I think is great
the effects on the ice are incredible
hmm like it's gorgeous to look at my one
gripe I'm not gonna say Disney's being
cheap because I think it's stylistic and
I'm not going to accuse the animators of
it anyway being cheap as a stylistic
choice the way the main characters are
animated that sort of tangled style they
look like Barbie dolls to me and it kind
of takes me out of it when I'm like wow
that ice is so incredible and I'm kind
of like there's the Barbie domain
characters like it almost just doesn't
quite mesh for me you know compared to
tangled because that was the one where I
was saying that the voices and the way
they look didn't quite match and it
seems strange and I don't know what
happened here maybe just got their voice
actors I don't know but uh it seemed to
mesh a little better by the lying if I
said to know what you're talking about
particularly for me it's the lips
particularly on the men's lips because
with women you can give them full lips
and that's easy but with men if you give
them full lips they look they look too
girly and kind of weird so they had to
sort of give them these kind of plastic
just slits for mouths and that they're
getting better but it's I'm sure we it's
the lack trying to figure out how to say
this the lack of detail and the lack of
tech
and it's very strange because when
you're into animation you notice certain
things and one thing I've noticed about
this style is there is texture there
they really nailed hair down they got
decals on and they've got the freckles
down but there's something about just
the nature of the skin and the body
shapes and everything that it just it
just feels dull like like we're not well
but let's be honest why they want to
sell it well yeah and their biggest
selling line is you know I mean it makes
total sense why they would look like but
it is sort of a there is a difference
between this in a really good Pixar
movie and even something like even the
animation something like How to Train
Your Dragon I'm gonna have to watch it
again but I felt that as stylized as
that was it didn't feel quite as
plasticky to me that the flesh was a bit
more the the design is still very they
still very much look like toys but
you're right the flesh it did seem a
little bit more fleshy okay well like a
good exam will be ratatouille hmm that's
very stylized
and you could argue there is almost a
plastic look to them yet they're so
animated and they're so stylized and it
just all blended so seamlessly with the
sort of Parisian world that they gave
you we really detail yeah it was a bit
more blurred and worn though there's a
lot of candlelight stuff in there where
this was very camp and very and when
they got out into the snow in this film
it really really works the opening I had
a lot of trouble with I was like I don't
know if I'm gonna be able to love this
animation because the world they created
it sounds terrible cuz I don't want to
say it's cheap it's just a stylistic
thing but it looks like a video game in
that sort of sense like this looks like
a video game made like five years ago
like it just has a very this is
obviously CGI quality and it was really
bugging me but it after a while it's
like I don't know if the animation got
better if I just got used to it but when
they go out into the mountains and the
ice effects take over really really
works and it's a very colorful film to
like the color scheme this movie was
great yeah we have all done a little
obviously at the snow but then like
I think the Anna character I meet just
say it wasn't like that purple and that
green agem and of that pop anyway so I'm
really up in the air about the animation
but somewhere in the middle of it when
they go to the ice fortress then she
grates or whatever I was sold
hmm so it was the same thing with the
movie the movie started off good in the
story Department but in the execution it
was kind of clunky to me and somewhere
in the middle of this movie I just
completely lost it was like I love this
movie that like only the only part where
I was a bit confused but they explained
later at least they allowed to to show
is why they had to keep the two separate
but then when you see how people react
to the power is it's like okay this
makes a bit more sense and being
political figures I can your queen it's
like it adds up I only think there's no
like at no point did she think maybe I
should tell my sister now that she's a
functioning adult because otherwise it
just looks like I being a raging
douchebag to my sister well eventually
eventually she does but I get you know
movies but but that comes into with the
you know with what she does to her later
and stuff I mean so there is I think
because she is such an emotional wreck
she's so afraid cuz the emotions seem to
feed uh seem to feed her power
oh and Disney thank you personally for
not making the reindeer talk i yea they
had there been a talking reindeer in a
snowman I would have walked no they are
two very clever and they sort of mock it
dude they mock a lot mine jasny
conventions which it in a smart wave
okay so you're still getting what is in
a lot of Disney film in different way
the guy the hero or the knight of the
arrow right she's the hero uh he's more
the side character he talks for the
reindeer
which is very funny and very smart so
it's like the reindeer is still talking
it's just input in the voice uh and the
same thing with uh meeting the boyfriend
in the beginning uh you know it's just
meeting and falling in love and the
Queen say what you just met and the way
in old vehicles as Omar said yeah and
the way that it's so smart and the way
it resolves is just and it's still
entertaining so you got good lessons
good morals good characters good cast uh
but it's still entertaining it's still
good story and it's still Disney still
feels like Disney as so hard to juggle
and
really got it this time in my baggy they
just really hit it solid I'll get you
next time you next so so so very well
done likes it we got a few issues with
the third egg mostly serve like some of
the political characters play into it
which we'll look into that in boiler
disney isms like it does yet a thing it
comes close and and falls back and
disney isms but but that kind of climbs
out again climbs up it i'm not gonna say
it's as good as Beauty and the Beast
i I can't take I do take issue with that
and I know there are people who hate
this movie so when I say this don't
think of this as a reason not to see it
to me
it's the Little Mermaid now and I nope
you're like no merit i but when you
think about what the lulu mermaid what
it did is it perfect no but when you
look at the animation that was coming
out of that studio before and the fact
that they really needed to capture
something old and reboot yeah are there
issues with the story sure there aren't
issues with this story so don't not see
it because i'm saying this but it's like
the little mermaid they upped the
animation to a certain degree they've
brought back sort of the broadway charm
only they've updated it yeah that's it's
updated but it still feels disney you
know these dough has that charm they've
given it a sense of purpose like no
we're gonna put out a really solid
product the comic relief's gonna be good
and not too jarring the story's gonna
take a few interesting turns and right
down to the fact that aren't both of
them hands christian andersen's stories
yeah actually that's true like right
down to like literally the setting that
was like huh kind of reminds me of
little more this looks like where she
washed up when she was trying to you
know bag the prince you know so yeah i'm
saying it's like The Little Mermaid I'm
not saying it's it does not have the
same problem so people does it it does
what the Little Mermaid did for Disney
yeah it's that sort of reboot you know
and so I'm saying is this is the step to
get to Beauty and the Beast if you want
a new Beauty and the Beast I'm not
saying this is beauty in the Beast this
is that stepping stone and it's a huge
stepping stone and we're really close so
I'm hoping that the next one they do is
going to be really amazing so but they
still
the issue here there it's like they're
still trying to figure it out but good
job yeah a really good job um my guess
is if you look at this movie and yeah I
think you can guess if this is the movie
you want to see honestly just it don't
does he feel like only the trailers it's
not about the stupid snowman it's not
about the reindeer you Rangers actually
ruin a man and as more man is almost
Indian it's more than just a tangled
Christmas it really is an old story and
it's not a tangled Christmas so take
that for what it's worth
take your good